шановні журналісти сьогодні - це брифінг
фракція європейського Солідарність щодо
переслідування депутатів фракцій
європейського солідарності Ігоря
хацевича та Олега левченка ми допитати
фракції європейської солідарності
вважаємо що переслідування
військовослужбовців збройних сил України
наших депутатів є прямим наміром влади
знищити місцеве самоврядування саме
сьогодні в річницю призначення татарова
саме він дав наказ щодо озвучення і
винесення підозри депутатам фракції
європейського солідарності
військовослужбовцям збройних сил України
ігри хоцевича та Олег Левченко ми
вважаємо що даними діями слідчі дбр
вийшли не просто за рамки закону а й за
рамки здорового глузду друзі Хочу вам
нагадати що саме ці
військовослужбовці збройних сил України
з першого дня повномасштабного
вторгнення записалися до Лав
територіальної оборони до 206 батальйону
взяли в руку зброю і стали захищати
місто Київ від рашиської навали
юридичної точки зору звинувачення дбр Я
абсолютно безглузденний оскільки два
військослу- військовослужбовці Хацкевич
і Левченко отримали прямий наказ свого
безпосередньо керівника відбути на
виконання завдань по відрядженню ось є
витяг з наказу де є от підписи їх
керівників це не Їх рішення було Це був
наказ в не виконати який у них не було
ні права ні можливості тому два
військовослужбовці відбули на виконання
наказу на роботу до військової
адміністрації міста Києва де я працювала
до березня 23-го року коли були
переведені іншим наказом відповідно до
іншого батальйону а ніякої Свободи волі
в прийнятті рішень яких не було окрім як
виконувати накази свого безпосередньо
керівництва Незважаючи на це дбр щодо
військовослужбовців які свого часу
добровільно записались до
батальйону територіальної оборони міста
Києва а ті самі працівники дбр які в цей
час коли ці
військовослужбовці підписували свої
контракти вони здриснули з міста Києва
до закарпатських регіонів так от ці
дбрщики Зараз їм пропонують встановити
межу запобіжного заходу
60 діб що означає що вони не зможуть
виконувати Левченко і хатцевич свої
повноваження Ані як депутат Київської
міської ради Ані як військовослужбовця
все що вони зможуть це на виконання
вимоги дбр тим хто поставив їм таке
завдання сидіти під арештом недаремно ці
хто
право слідчі дії цікавилися саме депута
діяльності військовослужбовців депутатів
на стирілової не приховано запитували чи
вони не є членами європейської
солідарності і більше того питали чи не
планують вийти з фракції
30% запитань було про політичну
діяльність саме тому ми переконані що
влада руками дбр намагається просто
дестабілізувати місцеве самоврядування в
столиці і передати його повноваження
військово цивільні адміністрації ми
рішуче проти наступу на децентралізацію
однієї на секунду з найуспішніших реформ
в Україні і ті хто зараз заважають
захисту нашій країні обов'язково
відповідатимуть за це і самі абоняться
на підсудній лаві фракції європейської
солідарності була обрана киянами для
того щоб захищати і служити місто Києва
наші депутати роблять все для цього як в
ла вах військовослужбовців так і на
посадах депутатів Київської міської ради
ми робили Ми захищали і будемо захищати
нашу єдину столицю як це від нас
вимагають тільки я на які обрали нас на
ці посади і хоче додати що саме
військовослужбовці
процеси України і депутати нашої фракції
Олег Левченко ігор ханцевич тільки днями
повернулася зі Слов'янська типу люди які
захищають наші кордони і борються за
нашу незалежність чомусь дбр за наказом
татарова зараз їм виписують підозри тому
дивно на цій стороні все-таки влади
наші колеги із фактів європейської
солідарності на рівні із іншими
українцями боронять нашу свободу наші
права і ми не дамо оцінювати жодну їхню
кропитку роботу Слава Україні героям